[Applause]
happy happy wednesday everyone or as i
like to call it hump day
a new report claims that hunter biden
shared bank accounts with his dad which
might be the least harmful thing hunter
could share with his dad
but it's still nuts think about it the
vp shared a bank account with hunter
that's like sharing a blow-up doll with
charlie sheen
no disinfectant will save you you just
burn it all down
normally this might be big news but
biden's last name is biden not trump and
the media only responds to corruption
when it's involving an orange republican
with a hot wife
and even then that corruption doesn't
have to be real but this latest news
means the president must become part of
the fbi investigation into hunter's
shady deals if the government wants to
go after rich people by tracking
everything over 600 bucks then hunter's
anonymous 75 grand checks should warrant
some scrutiny fact is like my luxurious
hair
the list of hunters outrageous
indiscretions keep growing
but when there's a democrat in charge
with the democrat media you can get away
with anything except telling the truth
from ted kennedy's driving to ilhan
omar's husband and or brother
it's all water and bodies under the
bridge
i almost wish i was a democrat why
didn't i become a democrat why didn't i
work at cnn could you imagine what i
could get away with i could grab my
producer's butt pal around with my
corrupt governor brother accidentally
expose myself on zoom and still i could
show up for work
i could also put x-lac x-lax and
stelter's grande mocha lattes
all eight of them
not that i would want that life i prefer
to keep my perversions where they belong
in the sauna room at planet fitness the
democrats never need to worry about
their sins
hell just as coach gruden loses his job
for racist comments and private emails
the media still gives a pass to hunter
for throwing around the n-word like he
was jimmy kimmel in a snoop dogg skit
so why was that okay well when your last
name is biden everything's okay if
you're hunter you can make six figures
for paintings that look like an old
janice joplin tie-dye t-shirt that james
taylor threw up on these are paintings
where he uses a straw coming from his
mouth
not his nose for once
still his paintings literally blow
and what if you bring this up to the
white house
i was hoping you could say the white
house knows who purchased the five
prince and whether there is indeed a
departure to the arrangement that there
would be an anonymity here i know this
is your favorite topic um but it again
it still is the purview of the gallerist
we still do not know and will not know
who purchases any paintings and the
president remains proud of his son
i know this is your favorite topic
yeah forgive us if we actually do give
about authentic corruption and collusion
but you go on and continue chasing down
parents for criticizing mass mandates
you hack meanwhile as we told you
yesterday right before hunter sold that
crap the gallery hosting him received a
half million in pandemic relief funds
far more than any other art gallery in
similar circumstances now why in hell
does a gallery need all that green to
rent a room to hire a half a sleep
security guard to get a velvet rope to
separate gawkers from the rottweiler
turd that is hunter's art
meanwhile all around the same town
businesses that have tons of employees
are shut tighter than the botox skin on
joe's forehead
yet hunter's gallery was saved by you
and me the taxpayer talk about
tax-funded abortions but like tyrus said
we all know people whose businesses have
closed permanently thanks to lockdowns
if only their dads had connections
instead those people are screwed under
life under joe we've got worthless money
bare shelves and elites who get special
treatment it's like the soviet union but
without the great literature meanwhile
we're told that all of these so-called
art transactions would remain anonymous
as if less transparency reduces
corruption but that's how we got a 3.5
trillion dollar spending spree that
somehow cost zero for them ignorance is
strength anyway how long before we find
out that whoever bought those paintings
is on some board for a company that pays
their employees in bat meat
all of this is happening on the year
anniversary of the hunter laptop expose
a true scandal that revealed how hunter
had sold influence while his pop was vp
and that his dad knew it joe got more
kickbacks than a horse proctologist
allegedly
but much like my latest unicorn tattoo
the story would not see the light of day
media the dams the big tech buried it in
order to change an election
wonder what his dad has to say
come on man i keep hearing about some
story that got buried there was no story
you want to hear a story i'll tell you a
story
there's an old saying in the art world
one man's trash is another man's
treasure i didn't say that you know who
did corn pop
the meanest pirate on the high seas
but i cut him down with one of my karate
chops
yes
so
we live in a world where parents are
targeted by the fbi for wanting to give
their kids a decent education
hunter however enjoys a carefree life
violating more laws than cat at
oktoberfest
the people the regular people get
screwed the elites don't that's the
lesson from hunter and it's not maybe
it's not his fault don't hate the player
hate the game or you can hate both
because there is no game without players
but hunter's just another political
crony living off connections sponging
off taxpayers cruising from one griff to
the next i'd say i'm disgusted
maybe i'm just jealous
tonight
yes
this bear never hibernates finally we
found a hard news man who's funnier than
kilmead special report host and author
of the new book to rescue the republic
bear
clearly the greatest writer ever named
hemingway fox news contributor and
author of rigged how the media big tech
and democrats seized our elections molly
hemingway
she's been stoned more times than people
in the bible boxes contributor cat tim
and even his small talk is gigantic my
massive sidekick in the nwa's world
television champion taurus
brett welcome to the show this is
fantastic first of all i've determined
that i need an audience for special
reports
i mean it changes the dynamic completely
it certainly does it certainly does and
they're wonderful very attractive people
yeah
afterwards um
after the show we often just take them
up uh to my hotel suite and we get
hammered
it's been really fun thank you so much
i'm with you
so if you had hunter's privilege
wouldn't you be tempted to do whatever
you want i mean he has no there's no
repercussions it's really amazing this
story think about when we covered it at
the beginning it was basically
us the new york post a few others and it
was prevented from going on twitter and
social media and now suddenly they're
the laptops real yeah and suddenly
they're answering questions real
questions about this um
it's a story that's not going away and
as long as they keep asking the
questions it'll still be there have you
ever met hunter you've been i have i
have a couple of times in d.c yeah were
you guys partying no
no we were not he wouldn't share woody
he's an interesting cat he's an
interesting cat you know what so
whatever that the word interesting is
always never a good thing
he's an interesting cat that's like get
the hell out of here get him away from
me molly you got a new book out too and
i haven't read it yet but i want to read
it it's called rigged and i think that
this you talk about the suppression of
the hunter scandal am i right absolutely
the book is about everything that
happened during the campaign that
affected the outcome of the election and
it was a huge thing that this hunter
biden story broke in october of last
year there were a few people who were
covering it it didn't go anywhere
because we're in this information war
where the media decide not to cover
something and it dies but big tech also
suppresses it and they you know it
wasn't just twitter banning the new york
post it was facebook
saying suppressing the story
artificially using what they call fact
checkers which are actually part of
their censorship team but
yeah hunter seems like an amazing person
to party with yes exactly that's the
upside about it the
the worse i the worst things i hear the
more i want to hang out with them but
there was another thing dude there was
like a there's a halo effect right that
because those people are you then you
feel like oh maybe i can't talk about it
either i can't talk about it because if
all of those people are saying don't
talk about it you know it's it reminds
me of the jesse smilet thing that we all
had to wait like five days right before
we said anything because or else if
because we never wanted to be first yeah
i tell a story in the book about how it
was suppressed because it took a lot for
for anybody to get it out not just the
new york post but the wall street
journal ends up sort of covering it and
the editorial page of the wall street
journal does a great job but do you
remember that jen sackey was one of the
people claiming that it was russian
disinformation they knew it wasn't
russian disinformation they knew it was
debate yeah it was in the debate yes joe
biden says that that's pretty amazing it
is incredible cat does it frustrate you
that you can't live the life of hunter
biden because they'll just come after
you every single day yes
because you keep saying he's a fun guy
and he sort of is but he's also not that
fun because if i could get away with
whatever i wanted okay like doing like
crimes and breaking rules is not
difficult right it's not hard i could
think of a million things i would do
the hard thing is to not get caught but
if you're in a situation where when you
get caught it doesn't matter yeah like
the sky is the limit he's kind of boring
almost yes you'd expect him to do more
things more crap like why
like he was smoking it yeah he ran out
why why aren't you making your own hire
a team of people to make your crack
using your
government credit card yeah
why not you get away with everything so
he's just not as creative in his
creative choices as i would have thought
so we would never work is what i'm
saying
another another wise romantic choice
i'm full of them
you you brought your a game for special
report
[Laughter]
one of these days will get to be on
special reports she's been doing for
five years makes all these jokes about
me doing drugs no it never happens
we just don't have that many crack
panels
well that in itself is a crime
she literally no i'm i'm gonna advocate
for you
she worked so hard to try to match her
pants to your time to show you i was
just just the co-host you've been
dreaming about
you know what now you've ruined it greg
i said i said before the show i asked
both of you to behave
oh but we weren't the one acting like
mom when she had a tupperware party and
i had my cleats on in the house you've
ruined everything don't do this he won't
come back like relax
relax now if i can be serious for a
moment yes this is the highest level of
addiction in an enabler yeah that's
exactly how i killed it just like that
i see that
this is this is what's why would you
ever allow your attic son access to
money yeah not to mention the american
people's money yeah it's it's
unbelievably disgusting and he's just as
culpable because if you if it was about
the love of my son he'd be in rehab
right now yeah he would be helping the
last thing you would ever allow your
attic son
would be access to free money yes that's
true
all right
i think we've learned a lot today i
think this is only the a block this is
the bike if you're in for a ride brett
we have a whole segment where we just
line dance nice yeah yeah
brought his boots hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else